La volta al món a peu, dia 270, crec. No n'estic segur.
Bueno, avui he dormit molt millor, eh? Una barbaritat de millor.
Clar, tampoc era gaire difícil de superar, eh?
Molt bé, tu, fresqueta. Marca 5 graus el termòmetre de l'aplicació.
No sé, no crec que no, eh? Crec que són més aviat 10. O 15 i tot, eh?
Bueno, tu, doncs, caminem 16 quilòmetres fins a la civilització.
Estic arribant al lloc on tenia previst acampar ahir, si no hagués acampat allà dalt,
a uns 4 quilòmetres de l'inici, i hi estan els portuguesos.
Els portuguesos que em vaig trobar al coi no van arribar fins al poble,
sinó que s'han quedat aquí. Quina gràcia.
Ha sigut molt divertit, cada cop i volta apareixo jo.
Bueno, una cosa que em sembla molt sorprenent i que no havia vist mai a la vida
és com baixa el riu. Aquest riu baixa marró, marró de pols, suposo, i de fang i tal.
Si hagués comptat amb aquesta aigua per rentar-me o per agafar l'aigua per beure,
doncs no hagués pogut, és el que em vaig quedar allà dalt, eh?
Bueno, anava per parlar amb ells, però hauria d'haver donat-ho a la volta i ja m'atraparan.
A la que recuïn en 5 minuts.
A la que recuïn en 5 minuts, m'atraparan.
Doncs ja estem al Pamir, regió de Gorno-Badakhshan,
perquè m'acabo de passar al primer checkpoint.
Bueno, no es creu que era una gran cosa, era un militar, amb una porta, i ja està.
Llavors, la idea és que tu li has de donar el passaport, no?
I ell s'apunta les dades, però clar, això és lent.
Llavors, el que em van recomanar a mi és que donés una fotocòpia del passaport.
Llavors ell se la guarda i ja està.
I això és el que he fet, sí, sí, i pum, i ha sigut ràpid,
perquè si no ha d'estar allà el tio apuntant i és com més lent.
No m'ha demanat el permís del Pamir.
Potser és per més endavant, el permís aquest, no ho sé.
Però sí, sí, bueno, doncs ja està.
Gorno-Badakhshan, bueno, és una regió que...
Que?
Ara crec que té el 2% de la població de Tadjikistan.
No sé si era el 2 o el 0,2, però ocupa el 40% del territori.
47% del territori.
O sigui que la densitat de població, bueno, ara no tinc els càlculs, però ja els farem.
D'acord, 10 quilòmetres per aquesta vall fins al poble.
I també he vist l'aigua Barrets, molt curiós, perquè com he canviat de vall,
doncs, baixa l'aigua.
L'aigua d'aquest riu gran, supertransparent,
i l'aigua que ve de la vall que vinc jo, l'embruta.
I ara està marró.
Està marró, no...
L'ha embrutat.
Mira, aquí tenim la senyal que ens indica els meus propers destins.
Joruk, a 240 quilòmetres, i el més important, Murgob, a 548 quilòmetres.
Murgob és l'última ciutat, encara que no ciutat, és un poble gran,
abans de la frontera amb la Xina.
És el meu destí.
I després d'allà, ja...
Uns, bueno, no sé si 70-80 quilòmetres.
50 quilòmetres fins a Xina.
Encara queden 500 mil quilòmetres fins a Murgob, encara queda una bona tirada.
I avui què?
Doncs, aquí ara ja a Afganistan, super a prop,
he arribat al poble aquest, que no recordo el nom.
És un nom una mica estrany, no és un nom de Jic.
És un nom de...
Bueno, de l'idioma que parlen aquí, que és un altre idioma que no és el de Jic.
Parlen el de Jic, però tenen altres idiomes també.
I, bueno, aquí a Afganistan, amb tot el seu esplendor just aquí davant, pam, eh?
La frontera entre Afganistan i Tajikistan és tot un riu que va seguint durant centenars de quilòmetres.
I a una banda és Tajikistan i a l'altra, Afganistan.
Els propers 240 quilòmetres, no.
Bueno, no sé, molts quilòmetres.
El que faré serà seguir aquesta frontera, d'acord?
I a una banda tenim Afganistan i a l'altra, Tajikistan, que és on caminaré jo.
Bastant, bastant loco.
Però, bueno, això ja serà a partir de demà.
Perquè avui el que faré serà quedar-me a un hotel.
Bé, això ja serà a partir de demà.
Sí, crec que... crec que m'ho mereixo i ho necessito.
Però, mira, en comptes de fer un dia sencer de descans, és a dir, estar dues nits,
el que faré serà arribar ara, són les deu i pico,
i doncs tinc tot el dia per descansar i demà, doncs tard, a les dotze o algun quan sigui,
ja començo a caminar.
Llavors, és com fer un dia de descans, perquè avui hauré caminat poc,
però, doncs, no perdo tants dies.
Està molt bé, està molt bé.
Bé, tu, doncs, he agafat l'habitació, no la més barata,
però no són barats, eh? Aquí els preus a Tajikistan,
ja us ho vaig dir a Dushanbe, que era una mica carillo tot el tema allotjament,
perquè, bé, només van guiris, hi ha poc turisme, hi ha poca oferta, doncs tal.
50 euros m'ha costat.
Pam! Però té pinta que l'habitació està molt bé.
Ara la veurem.
Que fort, tu! Aquí davant, Afganistan, mireu, mireu.
Hi ha el riu i una tanca amb unes canivetes aquí, perquè no...
entre ningú, i allà tenim una espècie de...
doncs no sé què és, sembla una escola, no?
No sé, uns barracons, unes casetes, poca cosa.
Mira, veig una moto allà.
Heavy, eh?
Bueno, hi haurem alguns pobles a l'altra banda del riu d'Afganistan.
És molt impressionant, eh?
Genial, genial l'habitació, els meus renclos, minibar.
Bueno, doncs passaré aquí la resta del dia.
Aniré a comprar, aniré a dinar, aniré a sopar, no?
Però, sí, sí, sí, sí, molt bé, tu.
Doncs al final del dia us faig resum.
La volta al món a peu, dia 271.
Res, ahir...
Com sempre que vaig a hotel,
després em fa mandra posar-me a gravar i tal,
i vaig dir, mira, saps què?
Ho deixem pel dia següent.
Doncs res, què vaig fer?
Doncs vaig anar a dinar, pum, això que veieu aquí, una mica de menú.
Espera, que activo la cancel·lació de soroll.
I després vaig estar tota la tarda a l'hotel.
Fantàstic.
Aquest matí m'han donat un esmorzar per dues persones.
Suposo que, clar, com tinc l'habitació doble,
em feia quedar el mateix que els que anaven de dos en dos.
Bueno.
Molt bé, he menjat més.
I ara, que són les 11 i 20, començo a caminar.
Estem a 1.300 metres sobre el nivell del mar, aproximadament,
i fa calor.
No fa tanta calor com a Duxambe,
però marca màximes de 31 avui, sí, sí.
Quin és el plan pels propers dies i setmanes?
Doncs ja no tornaré a fer ports alts,
com el que vaig fer aquests últims dos dies,
sinó que la qüestió serà anar pujant molt progressivament
fins als 4.000 metres, que es diu ràpid,
però serà empujada, a poc a poc, a poc a poc,
anar seguint la Pamir Highway.
I el futur més immediat, com ho vaig dir ahir,
és, mira, una oficina de megafon.
Potser m'hauria de fer de segona cim, eh?
Potser seria ara algun moment.
Bueno, acabo d'explicar-vos.
I...
Què diu aquest?
Val, sí, les properes setmanes...
No, la propera setmana, crec que una setmana,
seguiré la frontera amb Afganistan,
que són aquestes supermuntanyes d'aquí darrere,
i, doncs, m'aniré fixant molt què veig a l'altra banda.
Tinc molta curiositat.
Som-hi.
Val, al final he fet el de megafon, ja està.
Ja ho tinc.
I, bueno, no ho veieu, però aquí darrere hi ha una mesquita.
I m'he adonat que no he vist encara cap mesquita aquí en aquest país.
Bueno, sí, aquí hi ha gran mesquita, no?
Hello, how are you?
Hello.
La gran mesquita de Dushanbe, però no em van deixar entrar perquè estava tancat.
No sé si aquesta també estava tancada, però, bueno...
Està oberta la porta aquesta, però la porta d'allà no ho està.
Anem a veure.
Ah, bueno.
La mirarem des d'aquí.
Res de l'altre pot, no?
Està bé, però...
Sostre blau...
Bueno, ja està, ja ho hem vist.
Val.
Sí que comencen oficialment els 237 quilòmetres seguint la frontera amb l'Afganistan.
Aquí tenim aquest riu que separa els dos països.
Tenim una tanca que crec que seguirà tota o gairebé tota la frontera.
Per què?
Suposo perquè no emigrin els afganesos a Tajikistan.
No només tenen el riu, sinó que a més tenen una tanca perquè no puguin passar, no?
Aquí tenim, ara sí, bastantes edificacions.
Al costat afganès.
I, bueno, doncs no hi ha gaire diferència entre una banda i l'altra, no?
Com a mínim, en aquest tros d'aquí veig cases ben normals, amb el sostre de xapa, igual que a Tajikistan.
Veig arbres i muntanyes, bàsicament.
És el mateix.
Veurem algun talibà?
M'agradaria.
Altres primeres impressions d'aquest tram de l'autopista del Pamir, Pamir Highway,
és que, bueno, és una carretera bastant ampla, amb dos carrils i amb poca pols, més enllà del que hi ha aquí al costat, no?
Però que no hauria de ser una constant que cada cop que passa un camió em menjo la pols.
Ara!
Vull dir, d'aquí 20 quilòmetres potser canvia la cosa, però de moment anem bé.
D'acord, porto ja 4 quilòmetres.
Primeres impressions, no, seria segones impressions.
Molta calma, poc trànsit.
Segueix havent el tema de la poca pols.
Bé, poc trànsit també m'agrada.
Veig bastant de moviment al costat afganès.
Hi ha vist alguna dona amb burca?
No tinc clar ara si és obligatori, crec que sí que és obligatori per a les dones afganeses portar burca,
però no sé si totes el porten, eh?
També és veritat que estem molt lluny de Kabul, Kabul, la capital d'Afganistan.
Estem molt lluny, per tant no sé fins a quin punt és tan restrictiva la cosa.
Gent banyant-se, aquí darrere ja no tinc clar si és un home o una dona banyant-se una mica.
Remullant-se, i res, tot bé.
Allà darrere veiem un pont que és la primera de les fronteres que veurem entre Afganistan i Tajikistan.
No gravaré quan estigui a prop perquè, bueno, les fronteres ja sabem que no està bé per si a cas gravar-les.
No veig ningú que la creui.
Sí, probablement les restriccions de pas en aquesta frontera siguin bastant altes, sí, sí.
I no tot el reu, com podeu veure, aquí ja la tanca aquesta...
amb les ganivetes.
Hi ha trossos on no i hi ha militars vigilant.
Ara just aquí no n'hi ha, però m'he passat uns quants militars tajics que, bueno, doncs m'han saludat amablement i ja està.
Això sí, bastanta calor, eh?
Bastanta calor, més de l'esperada serà durillo.
Però crec que no serà la propera setmana gaire difícil, de moment.
Creuem els dits.
Ah, doncs sí, ara sí que he vist dues persones creuant el pont.
No, no ho sé.
I, per cert, la bandera afgana no és la tricolor antiga.
La van canviar els talibans i és aquesta blanca amb unes criptures que no sé què vol dir.
No t'entren ganes de creuar, Enric, la frontera?
Sí.
M'agradaria creuar i fer una volta i tornar.
No puc per dos motius.
Un, no tinc la visa afganesa.
S'ha de demanar i no la tinc.
I dos, la meva visa de Tajikistan és d'entrada única.
Per tant, si surto al país...
Després hi ha un servei per tornar a entrar.
Per tant, impossible.
Oi tant, oi tant que està obert.
I tenen menjar, a veure.
Un ventilador aquí dalt.
Mira, teníem bastant...
Tantes coses, però he agafat el pollastre amb...
Això no sé si és búrgol, llenties, no sé què és.
No ho sé.
L'amanida i l'sprite i el pa.
Buah.
Genial.
Bueno, segueixo caminant.
Són les quatre.
Atenció a això, eh?
Mireu quina és llavissada.
Però això ha sigut segur que fa quatre dies, eh?
Per què, home?
Ja ho haguéssim pogut treure amb una excavadora o una màquina que treguin això, pum.
I aquí està la carretera.
Això ha sigut fa quatre dies, eh?
I llavors t'has de desviar per aquí.
Pum, pum, pum.
Sí, sí, cap problema.
Un superbloc, eh?
Bueno, allà hi ha un túnel, però crec que malauradament no el podré creuar.
Esperem.
L'entrada del túnel està darrere meu.
Però no he volgut gravar gaire perquè hi havia uns militars.
Bé, és un túnel que, bueno, creua aquesta secció de muntanya.
I m'estalvia uns deu quilòmetres.
De tres i pico que té el túnel, doncs ara he de fer una volta de tretze.
I, bueno, ja hi comptava.
Ja hi comptava de fer aquesta volta.
Però, com podeu veure, malauradament, doncs, aquesta part, aquest desviament, no està pavimentat.
Els científics m'havien dit que l'obren una hora al dia, el túnel aquest.
Clar, jo no sabia quina hora era i tampoc se m'havien deixat creuar.
Bueno, doncs res, suposo que tocarà menjar una mica de pols.
M'he comprat una mascareta per portar-la per quan passi un camió o un cotxe.
No per portar-la tot el dia perquè fa massa calor i no cal.
Però just quan passa el camió o el cotxe, posar-me-la i així evitar, en aquell moment, menjar tanta pols, no?
El que passa és que ara la tinc guardada dintre la motxilla perquè, clar, és que estava pavimentat, no comptava amb això.
No comptava que fos així. Potser he de treure-la i posar-me-la.
Jo no sé si l'encostipat que m'ha agafat aquests dies, del qual ja estic millor però no 100% recuperat, al final era de la pols.
Potser no, potser no.
En qualsevol cas, el problema de la pols és una cosa que toca bastant la moral.
Ja, fins i tot, és com una cosa que...
que t'introdueix a la vida adulta, no?
O sigui, quan ets jove, petit, no hi pensis que sigui tan problema perquè són els teus pares els que netegen, no?
I no hi ha pols a casa.
Quan t'independitzes, de cop i volta dius, ostres, d'on surt tota aquesta pols?
Bueno, tu, mira, el millor per no tenir pols a casa, ja sabeu què és, no?
Clean and Iron.
Clean and Iron, empresa de neteja catalana que, si truques o demanes un servei a la web, sense parlar amb ningú,
S.O.S. Clean, doncs ve, a casa teva, te la netegen i et planxen la roba.
Clean and Iron.
Clean and Iron va obrint franquícies per tota Catalunya, ara han obert una nova a càrrec de la Raquel i el Xavi a Granollers
i m'han dit que us digui que busquen nous franquiciats a tota Catalunya, però especialment a aquestes comarques.
A veure si me'n recordo perquè no tinc un paper al davant.
A l'Empordà.
Vaig a Empordà.
Vaig a Obregat.
Garraf.
Maresme.
Tarragonès.
i Sagrià.
Visca, m'he'n recordat.
És un negoci que té 40 anys d'experiència, per tant, això sempre és una garantia, no?, de que si em prens, doncs funcionarà.
Aquí teniu la web en la qual obrir la franquícia amb un 5% de descompte si dieu que aneu de part meva.
Clean and Iron. Gràcies.
Fa estona que des de lluny, a la banda afgana del riu, veig unes taques blanques a la muntanya i dic, què és això?
Són cases? Vivendes? No pot ser.
No pot ser, però com s'arriba fins allà? I si sí, ara estic davant.
Hòstia, però és molt heavy, no? Però com pot ser? Com construeixes alguna cosa allà? Com arribes fins allà? Com vas a buscar menjar? Aigua? Qualsevol cosa.
Qualsevol cosa. No, no ho entenc. No ho entenc, és brutal, no? O sigui, les de l'esquerra encara, però i les de la dreta, que estan allà?
Però, tio, si això estigués a qualsevol altre lloc d'Europa o de qualsevol país turístic, seria una gran atracció dir què és això, saps?
Però aquí, està aquí, ningú ho coneix, ningú sap el que és.
Sí.
I flipes, no? No ho sé, tinc moltes preguntes, no ho entenc.
No, no ho entenc.
Bé, tu, els Tajiks són brutals. Ara m'he trobat un campament de militars. No he pogut gravar, però sí que he fet una foto.
M'han dit, vine, vine, i m'han donat això per menjar, patates, la carn, que no l'he tastat, però també pa i te.
He estat poc perquè me n'he d'anar, perquè, bé, jo avui hauria de carregar alguna cosa.
Bé, jo avui hauria de carregar aigua en algun moment i hi ha un poble que es diu Jorf, que està a 6,6 km i són les 6 i 7.
Per tant, arribaria ja una mica, una mica, una mica passat de l'hora de la posta de sol.
Bé, molta calor avui. Bastant durillo, eh? Bastant durillo.
Aquesta tarda, sobretot, he pensat que seria més fàcil la tarda, però no.
Ara sí, evidentment.
S'ha anat el sol o, bé, darrere les muntanyes hi ha ombra i ara sí que s'està millor.
Bé, vinga, va. Seguim.
Bé, les 7 de la tarda.
Com veieu, ja s'ha acabat el tram.
Aquest, allà està el túnel i ara s'uneix un altre cop en la carretera bona, asfaltada.
I deixem la Pols com a mínim de moment.
Queden uns dos quilòmetres per arribar al suposat supermercat o font.
Marca les dues coses, supermercat i font.
I a veure on acampo avui, perquè aquí l'espai és bastant limitat i ser invisible és bastant complicat perquè no hi ha molt d'espai per amagar-se.
Hello.
Bueno, estic ja a Jorf i abans del supermercat que marca el Mapi n'hi ha un altre, d'aquí a pocs metres,
que segons l'aplicació iOverlander està obert i no només venen aigua i menjar, sinó que també et deixen acampar.
Però té un truc, que és que has de pagar 10 euros.
Que és molt per posar simplement una tenda.
En aquest país, sí.
És molt.
Però, bueno.
Jo crec que passaré per l'arbre.
Sí.
Perquè per l'hora que és.
I bueno, tampoc vaig tan curt de calés.
Ja està.
Hello.
Bueno, em pensava que estava aixapat, ja m'anava a punt de rendir.
Però un home sense que jo digui res, ha vingut i m'ha dit, camping hotel?
Oh, oh.
Has tornat.
Yes, yes, yes.
Bueno, doncs ja ho tenim.
Ja ho tenim.
Camping? Yes? Camping?
Camping, no?
Camping.
Camping. Yes.
Rahmat.
Bona nit, amics i amigues, al jardí d'aquesta parella tan simpàtica.
El tio em diu, bueno, aquí tens l'aigua, pots fer-te una dutxa.
Vols sopa i cervesa?
I jo, home, vinga, va, fot-li, que som de Reus.
I aquí tenim la sopa amb un tros ben bo de carn.
Tenim pa, una amanida que ja m'he gelat, perquè el tio ha estat aquí bastanta estona intentant serrar amb mi.
I jo pensava que em portaria una llauneta de cervesa, però què va, m'ha portat això.
Un litre i mig de cervesa.
Fa!
I m'ha donat això de got.
A veure.
Fa!
Ostres, ho necessitava, eh?
Bueno, a veure, no sé si avui he fet els 7.000 quilòmetres ja.
Pels que sou nous, cada 1.000 quilòmetres per commemorar, per celebrar, em prenc una cervesa.
No sé si avui els he fet, però estic aviat...
aviat d'aconseguir-ho.
No ho sé perquè jo, com que vaig en retras amb els vídeos, perquè no he tingut internet,
doncs no publico l'estrava fins que no és el dia, per no fer espòiler,
i bueno, el comptador no va sumant, però bueno, crec que forai.
Forai avui, demà o ahir, no ho sé.
Bueno, tu, no sé si me l'acabaré, eh?
Fa!
Ui, tanca, me l'acabaré.
Potser avui veig el Barça i tot.
A les 12.
Bueno, aquí he estat veient els resums d'ahir i d'avui.
16 ahir, 38 avui.
Força bé.
Força bé, encara tinc sopa aquí, amb un bon tros de carn.
Molt bé, molt bé.
I bueno, de diners totals, entre ahir i avui, entre l'hotel.
Vaig rentar la roba.
Normalment la rento jo, a la pica, demà, però ahir vaig fer que me la rentessin a l'hotel i ja està.
Em va costar 5 euros.
Més supermercats.
Més el sopar aquest, més això.
82 euros entre ahir i avui.
Està bé, està bé.
Avui dia complicat.
No difícil logísticament, simplement era qüestió de caminar, però amb la calor complicat, però bueno.
És qüestió d'anar tirant i ja està.
El partit del Barça, doncs, crec que aquesta temporada no podré veure gaire cosa, perquè si no són a les 4, és a les 12 de la nit, el partit del Barça.
A menys que em dormi ara i em desperti per veure'l, no hi ha manera.
El que sí que podré escoltar o veure és el sorteig de la Champions, que és a les 6 de la tarda vostres, a les 9 meves.
Bueno, mira, sempre els sorteigs són divertits, no?
Molt bé, tu. Bueno, al final, un bon final de dia, eh?
Fa!
Ah, i una cosa, una altra cosa.
El tio m'intenta parlar en alemany.
I jo dic, ostres, no parlo alemany.
I m'ensenya, em fa així, i m'ensenya un tàtu.
De la DDR, la Deutschland Demokratische Republik, o algo així.
Que és la... bueno, quan Alemanya estava dividida en dos, era la part oriental, no?
No, sí, oriental.
O sigui, la comunista, no? No sé, no sé molt bé d'aquest tema, la veritat, però...
Sí, la que no era controlada pels Estats Units i no estava controlada per Rússia, no?
Ara potser m'estic ficant... m'estic ficant un fregat, eh? Però...
Bueno, total, no m'ha deixat fer una foto, llàstima.
Però m'ha fet entendre, perquè comunicació és difícil,
que havia anat allà, sí?
I m'ha dit Leipzig, no sé què, no sé quantos,
doncs, pobles, doncs, o en ciutats on no hi havia estat, i suposo que servint,
fa molts anys, no?
Molt bé, tu.
Malauradament, doncs, m'ha dit, secret, secret, no m'ha deixat fer la foto, el tàtu, eh?
Tàtu, eh? Un tàtu, atenció.
Vale, va. Demà més, senyors.
Bona nit, salut i bolets.
Bona nit.